i
declare
bankruptcy
i was never in this for the money
but it turns out that the money was an
absolute necessity for me
he's always been terrible with money i
bet his jam spending them straight to
the poor house yeah women be shopping
i can't believe he has a second job he's
not even good at his first one hey guys
what you talking about
okay i know what's going on talking
about jim and pam
if they're having sex what it looks like
michael i think hey hey hey
michael
are you having money problems monkey
problems now i'm not having monkey
problems
why would i have monkey problems i know
you heard me
correctly i hate monkeys what's going on
why do you have a second job
i don't have a second job
maybe
i am having an affair
with suzanne summers doesn't jan have
money i don't talk to my girlfriend
about money it is rude and unsexual true
it's best to hide our money problems
from women i totally agree with you but
i don't have money problems i bet
all right you know what
watch this
if i had money problems
would i do this
you just
well you're just going to bring me back
yeah yeah but i destroyed it it's not
even usable anymore i'm going to give
you a piece of paper i want you to write
down how much you want
and i want you to slide it back across
the desk to me
why can't i just
tell you because
that is the way these things are done
in
films
now slide sliders
oh
come on be serious i am serious mike
that's a 10 percent raise that's what i
want i can't give you that i i don't
make this much come on be for real mike
i don't i'll prove it to you
there is
pay stub
are you serious you earning this
plus perks yes mike this is barely more
than i make
you been here 10 years dawg
14 years oh
no please please oh sorry mike some more
folks got to hear about this ah
okay let's take 15 again
a boss's salary isn't just about money
it is about perks
it
for example every year i get a 100 gas
card
can't put a price tag on that
michael
here's the uh 15 i owe you no thank you
yeah i heard you might need it so
here's the 40 dollars you gave me i
didn't give you 40 dollars
in a way you did
yeah i heard how much michael makes
i still think he's way overpaid
i
declare
bankruptcy
hey i just wanted you to know that you
can't just say the word bankruptcy and
expect anything to happen i didn't say
it i declared it still that's
it's not anything
this is a lot of credit card debt yeah
tell me about it
you know jan has my credit cards and
she's
using them as if i'm made of money she
thinks i'm a human atm machine
okay 125 amazon
oh best of them upper show on dvd
classic
twelve hundred dollars what's a core
blaster extreme that is by far
the best way to strengthen your core
this machine
you sit on a stabilizer ball you put
your feet into the power stirrups you
reach up and you grab onto the super rod
and you twist and you twist and you
twist it strengthens your entire core
your back core
your arm core
your
the marine core actually uses it i think
that's how they got core okay the green
bar is what you spend every month on
stuff you need
like a car and a house
that's so cool hey you have my name at
the top
the red bar
is what you spend on non-essentials like
magazines entertainment right things
like that
this scary black bar
is what you spend
on things that no one ever ever needs
like multiple magic sets professional
bass fishing equipment how do they do
this so fast is this
powerpoint
what's wrong with you
i don't know
it was a weird day
i accidentally cross-dressed
and then daryl made me feel bad for not
making any money
and then i had to ride up here with
stupid toby and then
your assistant was all young and hot and
i
okay michael
i can offer you a 12 raise but
you have got to ask for 15.
well that's ridiculous i'm never gonna
make just
i just need you to ask for it
so i can record that you asked for it
okay
ah so
all right
levinson
here's the rub
i would like a 15
raise no but we can offer you 12.
but you just said 15.
and then i just need you to sign here at
this era what kind of mortgage did you
get
uh tenure
well
10 over 30. so 30-year tunnel
what what
you said
10 year fixed
over 30 30 year total oh 30 years okay
okay
wow you'll be paying this off in your
mid-70s
forget about retiring when you're 65.
hey i got an idea you know that extra
bedroom if the whole girlfriend thing
never happens that's where the nurse can
live okay all right
oh boy yeah this is it whenever you're
ready yeah
oh um okay is that supposed to come off
hey look cool carpenter ants um
i'm gonna take a little uh breather for
a second excuse me
it'll be here waiting for you oh man
a 30-year mortgage at michael's age
essentially means that he's buying a
coffin
if i were buying my coffin
i would get one with thicker walls so
you couldn't hear the other dead people
oh whenever you're ready michael
oh
i already have the ring don't think you
need the corpse then there's a ring
holy is that real yeah they say
three-year salary oh
is she not gonna like that no she's
gonna love it well i just want to take a
minute to talk to you all about
something very serious once every hour
someone is involved in an internet scam
that man is michael scott
he's supporting about 20 nigerian
princesses hey you know what
forgive me for caring right
what am i doing i am
blowing dodge
i'm getting out of town
whatever you call it i am running away
from my responsibilities
that feels good
i hate disappointing just one person
and i really hate disappointing everyone
but i love
burlington coat factory
you going there 645
you are literally a king
what did we learn this week well one
thanks to me
my team is much much faster coming to
decisions than i thought they would be
number two
never buy a fur coat with a credit card
until you absolutely have the money to
pay for it
and three
you should know that some people think
it's cool to throw buckets of fake blood
on you as you were walking out of
burlington coat factory
i'm sorry i'm so sorry you lied to us
yep i lied to myself too
i'm not a millionaire
i thought i would be by the time i was
30 but i wasn't even close and then i
thought maybe by the time i was 40
but
by 40 i had less money than when i was
30 maybe by my 50s i don't know
my money my problems
i was never in this for the money
but it turns out that the money was an
absolute necessity for me
you